hello this is white coming up on the
show we take a look at the tech tackling
flooding i brace myself for a bionic
workout and prepare for prehistoric
battle as we look ahead to the big games
coming out in the new year
welcome to swipe from the thames barrier
an engineering feat designed to protect
London from flooding when storm
Desmond's hit the UK recently thousands
of people in the northwest of England
had to leave their homes because of
rising water now we might never be able
to control the weather but there is
technology that can help us adapt to it
here's will this is what Cumbria looked
like after storm Desmond crashed into
the UK the already saturated ground
couldn't cope with the heavy rainfall
and towns like Carlisle were devastated
but could the introduction of new
technology help to lessen the effects
this robots been used in Wales to remove
debris from rivers last year it helped
to prevent flooding by shifting 400 tons
of gravel from the river Neath in just
two days
Robo dozers are really small and compact
so they can fit nicely underneath the
bridge and the operator can stand
outside of the bridge the Robo dozer
goes under there pushes the river gravel
out and then our excavators are able to
reach into the river channel pick up
that gravel and load it into lorries and
take it away from the site one of the
biggest problems in urban areas is flash
flooding
well this thirsty concrete could be part
of the solution it's not designed to
stop floods but its ability to absorb
water could help drain steel with heavy
rain it came about because of flooding
of this nature that damage damaged
properties especially back in the 2007
floods where most of the the damage to
properties was caused by flooding that
was down to runoff water and overflowing
drains
so these types of products were
developed as an answer to that
particular problem the wettest November
for more than 20 years turned the Indian
city of Chennai in
this but despite the impact technology
was instrumental in helping people
handle the situation Google set up a
crisis response page and used
crowd-sourced data to create these Maps
users could report flooded streets by
clicking on an area and zoom in for more
detail the role of social media and
technology in responding to disasters I
think can only increase especially as we
see things like a smartphone adoption
grow around the world I don't think
it'll be too many years before before we
really start to see this being the de
facto way to respond to emergencies
technology will never be able to cancel
out flooding completely but it could
help to make the effects less severe
we'll Sergeant Sky News you're watching
swype still to come I get a go on a
bionic knee brace designed to increase
my leg power but first here's a quick
roundup of what else has been going on
in the world of tech this week here's a
way to record virtual reality videos on
your phone the teleport VR system uses a
headset and camera that connects your
smartphone via an app it's two lenses
have been designed to mimic our eyes so
they can create 3d video so far it's
raised more than 60 thousand dollars on
IndieGoGo and while we're talking
virtual reality HTC has finally given a
release date for the vibe it'll go on
sale in April but we haven't yet been
told how much it'll cost back in August
we tested a prototype at Gamescom and
although it was impressive it did have a
few too many wires hanging off it
the creators behind this say it's the
world's safest drone the fly has a
curved body that covers all moving parts
which means you don't have to look out
for those sharp rotor blades you can
also program it to react to what it sees
and it's about the same size as a
football
coming up what does uncharted 4 have in
store for us find out in our games
preview now for something completely
different
knees they deal with a lot of strain
day-to-day don't they maybe that's why
knee injuries seemed to be so common so
when I heard about a bionic brace that
could make my legs stronger of course I
wanted to go so can you feel that as it
kind of as you stand up yeah it kind of
propels me exactly so it's a
spring-loaded brace that's loading
energies you bend down and then
releasing that energy to push you back
up and you describe it as a bionic knee
brace what is it that makes it Bionic so
it's Bionic because it can enhance your
natural capabilities so it can actually
augment the strength of your leg muscles
so during this movement again it's
loading in energy as you bend down and a
spring-loaded mechanism that's actually
embedded in the hinge right here in the
arm and it releases that energy as you
straighten your leg did you design it
specifically for athletes yes so we
designed it both for really active
people athletes people that are doing a
lot of crouching and bending and kind of
you know this movement while you're
skiing or perhaps playing a racquet
sport and lunging out like this as well
as people that have difficulty with
everyday mobility so standing up from a
seated position you can imagine how hard
this is for a lot of people knee
injuries seem to be so common exactly
and same with osteoarthritis you know as
it's almost inevitable that you know
half of us are going to develop
osteoarthritis then and this movement
becomes difficult so we can really help
with that to get people back on their
feet on their own can you make you a
better jumper yeah so actually because
it can release energy you know if you've
had an injury it can help you propel
sort of through that movement to push
you back up and kind of restore your
your natural athletic ability and this
is just a prototype at this stage so
once you streamline it do you hope that
people will just get one for each leg
and wear them under their trousers just
out and about yes a lot of people will
get to for sure that's that's a large
size on you that's not the right size
it's kind of falling off but yeah so
it'll be quite streamlined you can wear
blue shorts your pants
and a lot of people will wear - others
will wear just one if they've had a and
the injury just on one side but so very
kind of by what their needs are 2015 has
been a massive year for games but we
don't want to keep looking back let's
look forward
here's Lucy James with some titles to
look out for in 2016
first off uncharted 4 so it's develop my
studio called Naughty Dog and they are
sort of the absolute best at immersive
storytelling big action set-pieces lots
of explosions really tight scripts
really great characters the basic
premise of the of the Uncharted games as
you play as Nathan Drake who's this
Indiana Jones Lara Croft esque
treasure hunter in uncharted 4 he's
retired now he's settled down and his
brother comes out out of the woodwork to
sort of get back in the game and it's
gonna be this great big mishmash of
action adventure gunplay and pouring
climbing around old ancient
dog sauce 3 is the latest in a long long
running series now of very very
difficult role-playing games it's a slow
and measured game and everything in that
game will try and kill you and it's
gonna be more of the same more of the
dark fantasy world with you know you can
be a warrior it can be a mage wizard
sort of character and you basically just
have to try and survive but dogs'll
doesn't very doesn't tell you much about
the world you're in you get maybe like
an intro cutscene and then the rest of
the game if from its gameplay to finding
out even while you're supposed to go you
have to find that out by yourself so if
you like a challenge Dark Souls 3 is
definitely the one for you comes out in
March in Japan
April worldwide on PlayStation 4 Xbox
one and PC when you play Far Cry games
you expect things like guns explosions
vehicles a beautiful world and if I cry
primal you're only gonna get one of
those things which is a big beautiful
world so far cry primal takes away the
guns takes away the modern day and takes
you back in time twelve thousand years
to the Stone Age where you plays this as
a hunter you're a caveman essentially in
previous five-hour games you could sort
of release trapped wildlife to take out
bad guys for you but this time you can
befriend the animals you can become a
dr. Dolittle and and talk to the animals
and pet them and they become your
companions so in a world with mammoths
and saber-toothed Tigers you can
befriend these creatures and hand in do
your bidding essentially Far Cry primal
is out in February on all current gen
concepts that's it for this week take a
look at Chinese on mobile and iPad for
some bonus features from this week's
episode I'll see you again next time bye
bye